10 días después del descarrilamiento de
un tren en Ohio que causó un grave
impacto ambiental los vecinos al de años
a las vías férreas dicen sentirse
enfermos por los químicos tóxicos en el
agua y el aire he tenido dolores de
cabeza dolor de garganta mi nariz gotea
y mis ojos lloran constantemente como
con ardor picazón los temores entre
estas poblaciones no son infundados
según expertos ya que el accidentado
tren operado por North Food Corporation
transportaba al menos cinco productos
químicos tóxicos como cloruro de vinilo
asociados con diferentes tipos de cáncer
esto también lo demuestran los peces
muertos hallados en las vías fluviales
cercanas
el mayor problema con la respuesta en
este momento es el hecho de que las
agencias estatales y gubernamentales
locales no han sido transparentes con
los datos que tienen y cómo están
tomando decisiones sobre el envío de
personas de regreso al área y si el agua
en el área es o no segura
la agencia de protección medioambiental
estadounidense ordenó a la empresa pagar
la limpieza del accidente ferroviario y
el partido químico una medida respaldada
por el presidente Joe biden que señaló
que responsabilizará a las empresas
ferroviarias que no antepongan la
seguridad
si la empresa no completa cualquier
acción ordenada por la Epa la agencia
intervendrá de inmediato realizaremos el
trabajo nosotros mismos y luego obligará
el triple del costo de acuerdo con los
poderes otorgados por mi agencia
por su parte el responsable del
accidente aseguró estar de centrado en
Reparar los daños medioambientales
generados con los vertidos así como
mejorar las medidas de seguridad para
evitar futuros desastres